it's not hysterical to say that the kova
19 quarantine and mass national lockdown
which we've never seen in american
history despite
our long experience with plague
encouraged the destruction of the middle
class in general and the middle class
business person in particular
and it championed or enhanced or
empowered
large corporations that were vertically
integrated the amazons the targets the
social media companies the zooms now how
did that happen
well think for a minute if you sold
shoes
and you were a small business you were
shut down
if you
sold flowers you were shut down if you
had a small restaurant you were shut
down
if you
had a small business that
repaired watches you were shut down if
you sold phones you were often shut down
and yet you could go into walmart
you could go into target you could get
something to eat fast food
you could buy shoes you could buy socks
you could buy anything and when you went
into walmart or you went into target or
you went into any of these large chain
stores what did you see you saw hundreds
of people congested
in there it was very different than the
experience of going in opening the door
the little bell rang there might have
been one or two customers you knew the
small business person you could say the
small have you been vaccinated have you
had covet all of that interpersonal
relationship that's so innate to small
communities and small businesses
but whether by intent
or just accidentally or laxity we
essentially said to the small business
person
you obey us
and you're going to shut down your
business and you have no power to object
you have no capital you have no vertical
integration you have no influence and
then we said to the large corporation
people during this lockdown will still
need to have shoes they'll need to buy
clothing they'll need to buy food
they'll need to buy
durable goods and appliances and we pick
we select you
to be the conveyor of that and you're
exempt from the lockdown
because we trust that you're large and
you're efficient and you're wealthy and
we've dealt with you in the past through
political packs and donations and
influence and so
it doesn't take a conspiracy to see
empirically that the middle class and
the middle class business person
suffered enormously under covet
lockdowns and quarantines and large
corporations got larger and more
powerful and more dangerous
[Music]